thomas votre soeur et les parties
ces gens sont des blasphémateurs leur
secte est une gangrène
hélas non thomas richardson d'avoir eu
l'audace de rêver d'un monde dans lequel
on se réveille tous les matins en étant
égaux 7e c'est notre paraty il y à un
intrus sur nos terres nous devons
trouver
facile il est enlevé certaines choses
qui et de quoi ils soient purifiée selon
le rituel de cette terre la promesse du
divin n'est rien de plus qu'une illusion
dieu et douleur il est souffrant
méfiez-vous des faux prophètes qui
viennent à vous déguiser en brebis
alors que dedans ça sont des loups
fouras commençons
[Applaudissements]
tout prix senior pardon